COVID-19 was disastrous for Latin America.
Not only because of a death
rate eight times higher
than in the world at large,
the pandemic has also
created the preconditions
for a resurgence of left wing populism,
that poses a threat
to personal freedom and economic wellbeing
throughout the region.
Following months of violent
protests in Colombia,
Gustavo Petro became the
leading presidential candidate,
with proposals to raise
taxes, seize private land,
expand entitlements, and kneecap
the oil and gas industries.
In Peru, the socialist
president, Pedro Castillo,
was elected with the promise
of weakening property rights,
and rewriting the constitution
to allow for a dramatic
expansion of state power.
In Argentina, President Alberto Fernandez
has responded to rapid inflation,
and a shrinking economy,
by imposing price controls, raising taxes,
and growing the regulatory state.
And in Chile, although
poverty has plummeted
in the last 20 years,
voters opted to redraft the constitution,
which could enshrine into law
more government intervention
in the economy, while weakening
private property rights.
Argentinian born libertarian,
the Atlas Network's associate director
at the center for Latin America,
and the author of four
books about the region.
In 2018, Marty had a televised debate
with Juan Carlos Junio,
a prominent communist
political leader in Argentina,
who exemplifies this problem
of exalting political figures as saviors.
This attitude was on display
at a 2016 celebration for the
Cuban dictator, Fidel Castro.
The Castro Regime impoverished the nation,
drove over 1.4 million to flee,
and murdered thousands of dissidents.
In 2018, Marty debated Patricio del Corro,
a socialist and congressional
representative for the city of
Buenos Aires.
"This misconception that the
rich are rich because the poor
are poor" Marty says,
"traces back to the 'Open
Veins of Latin America.'"
Five centuries of the
pillage of a continent,
published in 1971 by the
Uruguayan writer, Eduardo Galeano.
It sold over a million copies,
and the Venezuelan socialist
leader, Hugo Chavez,
famously gifted it to president
Obama at a 2009 summit.
"The winners happened to have one thanks
to our losing" Galeano wrote.
"Our defeat was always implicit
in the victory of others;
our wealth has always
generated our poverty
by nourishing the prosperity of others."
In 2019,
Marty debated the Colombian
political scientist
and aspiring politicians Sergio Fernandez,
who believes that the United States
is the world's wealthiest country
because of its protectionist policies,
and that Latin America
should follow its example.